where did all this call out come from I
know obviously you competitors in the
market well three years ago you were
talking about kicking my ass oh you
think I said would you put money on that
and he went yeah 50 Grand
[Music]
theft
how seriously have you taken this I'm
scared like a world champion I've
already won the fight okay I already
worked out how to win the fight I've
already won the fight what do you think
is going to be the conclusion of the
fight Massacre
that's how I feel I'm very comfortable
I'm very confident in the ring I'm not
stressed at all
[Music]
talk outside
it's my little my little home gym guys
so the track is that your main piece of
training equipment this little one there
the blue one
or do you generally flavor the red and
the yellow vehicle so basically I got my
battle ropes right
I got my punch bag
I got some light weights for the student
Shadow Boxing and that yep skipping rope
so when I started working with Samuel
the goal was we said six pack in six
months that was the kind of the plant so
we started working together and we got
him to lose a decent amount of body fat
I think we did about 10 kilos in a space
of a couple of months but then he tells
me he's got a boxing match against
rubber I know that the greatest boxers
in the world aren't always the most
aesthetic I mean look at Tyson Fury the
guy is freaking Unstoppable but he's not
exactly Brad Pitt and Fight Club is he
so it's like right I've got to get
Samuel ribs but then I've also got to
make sure that he's fit for a boxing
match and that he wins the boxing match
more importantly so it kind of changed
the plan with regards to what we were
going to do with his physique a little
bit
I was thinking like just a bench
pressing that on here yeah I mean really
what you need is a power cage
yeah so if you've got a power cage you
can bench you can do all that kind of uh
compound stuff I've got a medicine ball
right nice but he wants to look freaking
amazing and he's got he's got the height
for it so he's got the long limbs he's
got the frame to build a really good
physique
but doing just boxing training isn't
going to get in that look so we'll
probably keep incorporating the cardios
type aspects he's doing but now we're
going to focus on nutrition getting him
rips up and just building some serious
muscle so quite excited about it because
the goal is obviously we want to get you
looking good we want you functional as
well so if uh if Rob Moore should decide
that he's brave enough a rematch or if
you destroy him then you don't want to
rematch
why this is important to Samuel now and
I love this freaking little sound bite
I've got the house I've got the wife
I've got the kids I've got the wealth
I've got I've built everything
but I'm a fat bastard and actually
despite being massively confident he is
quite you know body conscious and aware
of how he looks and he wants to kind of
portray that all around image really
[Music]
I've known Samuel since 2014. so Fitness
hasn't been something that Sarah always
did like when I first met him
I'd say the first time that he got into
it that I saw was when we just had our
first baby
when I went on maternity three months
before having our baby he was like oh
I'm also gonna just like stop working
and I'm just gonna be at home with you
because he wanted to really immerse
herself with being a dad he was just at
home and he was bored all the time and
he had so much energy because he wasn't
working and then he decided to sign up
for an MMA fight
[Applause]
the first time I think that I've seen
him really get into something and push
forward with all the fitness
and he did win his MMA fight
and yeah then I'd say it's kind of been
in fits and starts so he gets bursts of
times when he's like right really want
to be fit and then he'll kind of just
fall off a bit
when he started getting fit for this
boxing match I think that's after a year
of sort of just not being in that
headspace of wanting to be fit so it
kind of we started to rebooted him again
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
my name's Sully personal trainer Fitness
coach doing this for about 10 years now
so we started about February end of
February so you know coming up to four
four-ish months for in a bit months so
five months by the time you get there
[Music]
I think Sully and him get on really well
and so he is so professional but I think
they have a bit of banter but I don't
know you could do such good massages
this time really needs that he wants
someone that sort of can just kick his
ass because Samuel's quite brutal with
his clients and his student and I think
he needs someone who can be the same
with him in Fitness not someone who's
soft and wants to let him off like silly
is really really strict and hard
[Music]
I've been training him literally how I
train for my fights because I still my
last fight was last year I'm training
and pushing them hard and he does
Everything is Everything I make him do
so
foreign
[Music]
exhale then inhale straight away
all right every single time
[Music]
yeah
so I'm gonna finish Rob overhandle body
finished
[Music]
one more one more big big big
that one that's all you gotta do man
smash the body smash what he's going to
give you his hands are going to drop
he's going to give you his head that's
where another van comes
and now we're here in Barcelona we've
got the heat we've got the you know a
little bit of humidity as well different
environment we did it on the beach so
when we was on the sand we had a lot of
resistance so that was really good that
was really hard training in the sea as
well getting resistance so it's
different terrain different environment
look at the Target look at the top yes
you want the liver look at it
thank you
whip it whip it smack it
[Music]
I don't think many people know how to
train this hot I've pushed myself very
hard so I don't give my Fighters
anything less I'll push them to the
limits that they can do and then a
little bit more too so there's no erupts
getting this country and there's no way
we're up sparring with the level of
people that Samuel's been inspiring with
there's no way so I see it it's going to
be very difficult for Rob to to do
something so only way a Rob can do
anything is if Samuel literally lets it
back to back
about an installer I'll look forward to
Knocking you
correct
watch the equipment
[Applause]
my whole legs was stiff
last night
I announced for the very first time that
Sally was my trainer because I've been
keeping that secret because I didn't
want if everyone knew that Sunny was my
trainer I might get my opponent Rob like
trying to being able to see stuff so I
kept I just thought it'd be better to
keep it quiet
that was the fight
it's only like a week away now
I thought I'm gonna I'll understand it
it went crazy violence had like
thousands of likes and stuff yeah it's
cool
because I'm I'm massively into honoring
those to help yourself I've had to be
super quiet about it but I've been
constantly wanting to post but it was
good to be able to do that
even though he taught just me yeah
[Music]
I met my
when I was like 19 20 I used to fight
for fun and I had you know I had it
always had it in me to fight it's fun
but then when I was like you got a bit
older became wealthy my business put
weight on
what are you fighting for there's
there's nothing and then I thought
recently I was like I'm 32 years old now
if I stay fat and they'll never do it by
the time I hit 40 it's like oh I could
have if I'd have tried nah man I didn't
want to be like a has been or one of
those guys that are like well I when I
was 19. it's like no man I want to fight
now and I want to be the best version of
myself now have I gone too far do you
detect something different if
we
every time I have a session we're so
late he always finds a way to make it
harder than the last session so
yesterday on the beach it was hard
keeping your footwork in the sand moving
around it was exhausting but then today
he had me running on 18 on the treadmill
which is as fast as the treadmill goes
but you know they say train hard fight
easy
so I'm looking forward to the fight I'm
not expecting it to be easy
but I am expecting it to be a win
I'll tell you something interesting
about six months ago when I first
started trying to box a little bit
we decided all my staff would have like
a bit of a um a staff competition we
were sent to parks to me it'd be all the
guys my friends my sales guys my
property friends and we're all boxing
and it was fine and we're all kind of
messing about boxing now
I can't do that anymore because now if I
bring any of my friends any normal
person to come and Spa with me at my
house
they're getting banged up that's why
you're now bringing down these guys
kicking my ass which humbles me because
it wasn't for you bringing those guys
now I'm I might be thinking I'm so good
I'm brilliant but because
you're bringing guys down that are
actually good that kind of you know come
back on a Sunday Central Amanda I'm not
that good actually I thought it was good
it's it's humbling
[Applause]
one of the realest gyms we could find
recommended by someone on Instagram when
we got here and I've asked if I can Spa
with the uh the guy I've been dealing
with I don't know who he is he said yeah
you can spot at the end
and I'm watching them spa and the one
guy the black guy has cleared out a lot
of fights I've got a feeling that he's
going to want to spy me and he looks
tough so we'll see how that goes that
should be fun
[Music]
thank you
oh
my God
okay so the warm guy in the gym who's
prepared to spar with me wants to move
from Spain because the level in Spain
for boxing is not good enough she wants
to move to America
and now I'm about to spar him I'm ready
let's see what happens
[Music]
every time
super tired he was going a bit easy on
me I think but
maybe uh made me miss made me pay
but
it's not an easy sport man not an easy
sport at all I'm trying man no I don't
think so I don't want to say that to you
mate you know what silly was the same
silly was like she didn't want to make
me have a confidence he was saying like
nah man he's quicker than you he's got
better riches but then as we're getting
closer and goes to the fight Natalie's
like
I think you're gonna [__] him up bro
[Music]
every week just getting rounds inspiring
training with him as well with obviously
coach Sally doing well like he's come
leave some bounds so when I first
started with him you can see like the
termination's always been there we're
just about getting the technical ability
the skills up and it's one thing watch
them fight or when you're in there with
him you can feed it like as the week's
getting better you're having to think
more you have to be more calculated like
making sure that your defense is up
right because not like it's a big boy
he's got heavy hands I mean he actually
clean or whatever no matter who you are
[Music]
I'm not really into boxing I've not
really done much before my background's
in like Fitness and Crossfit and stuff
I've mad respect for people like Samuel
on the journey that has gone from like
the weight loss and the transformation
that he's done
[Music]
a really good spot to kind of dive into
shows discipline issues resilience and
you've got to go through like so many
different aspects of Fitness to be good
at it I think it's a really good spot to
get into
foreign
experience I'm not used to it but he
left me with a nice nice bloody nose at
the end so
[Music]
so I've been chained with Sally Porter I
would say I started summer he hit me off
yesterday said that you want to go
Sporting Good Sam and a couple other
guys and obviously
couldn't turn down that opportunity on
here I am
surprising very tough definitely a fifth
game it's like you got hit by a chain
almost very very powerful
I can move around as much as I could
obviously because I knew that he had a
purple shot but I was quite surprised
how well he controlled the center and
corn me essentially to clean up my
options sent it for the movement
three two minutes round three Sam off at
the top top five I work at ABC
[Music]
somebody first got in the ring oh you
got a big hill but he's climb these uh
he's far past the knob is he's a very
good amateur now yeah you can handle
people he's good he's very good
[Music]
remember the first time we were Boxing
Around ice is running around the river
now he's fine you know he's healthy he's
a little bit he's been doing cardio I've
never seen somebody so dedicated at
anything they do and fit this and just
gain to a point yeah he's always stepped
up amazing I should have dropped him
though should have dropped him
this time feels like I think I think
it's almost like a lifestyle change I
really think this time he's just gonna
stick with it now I think with boxing
he's found it being fun
usually it's been like all working out
but it's not easy to do something that
doesn't excite you whereas with boxing I
think he actually enjoys it so I think
if he carries on just training with
trainers doing Fitness through boxing I
think he's gonna sort of keep it up now
forever
[Music]
118k Gmail it only started so but he
hasn't missed one Sunday of spot since
then he's turned up to you know every
training session
which I'm happy about it makes sense
when you do something like boxing and
the training four bucks in that's what
happens man
you're feeling deadly for Saturday mate
yeah
nice yeah no I'm totally very man
excited hmm
what's your prediction Samuel
my prediction I'm going for a knockout
in round two yeah nice
yeah do you know anything about Rob's
fighting you kind of know strengths
weaknesses yeah I think he's going to be
like I think he'll fight like this
well I'm terrified already no that's
that's genuinely yeah what was that is
that Drunken Monkey Style what would
they call that kind of thing I think
he'll fight like like very runny away
keeping it like this and every time I
come in I'm coming now if you come at me
if you're coming back in the five months
we've been working together we dropped
about 45 50 pounds so we've done about
20 kilograms so about about a freestyle
or so as far as I'm concerned to be able
to speak for four days a week running
these crazy seminars where we had to
build them with Nando's nutrition plan
where his team would literally I went
for the Nando's menu and his team were
just grabbing bits from the menu and
made sure he stayed on point to be able
to do that to be running his big team
into all of those things and be you know
go on a holiday from time to time boxing
for an hour a day and still lose that
much weight and you know I'm pretty
truffed with what we've achieved
right moment of truth right so yesterday
I was 59.6 oh exactly so breathing super
ambulizer oh
so did you sir
oh yeah
15 salad what the hell did you do that
to crack the salad did you do something
I might do that oh go on again and
you'll see it's the same that's mate
it's amazing
you've got it she already smashed your
goal for work
my predictions for Samuel's fight are
first and Samuel's gonna kill me I I
thought no he's not going to do it when
I saw the First videos of inboxing I was
I wasn't that convinced but recently I
mean his stabbing has gone through the
freaking roof and actually when he came
to my gym and I saw him I did some pad
work with him Boya can hit like his
right hook he's pretty freaking
dangerous he really he can really
connect so yeah I've completely changed
around now and I think yeah I think
Sammy was going to uh I'd like to see
Samuel knock him out very least he's
going to put some blood on his face
Samuel win I predict it will be a
knockout I think it's gonna I've heard a
little bits about Rob Moore in his
background but if Samuel's been putting
in the work of our disease today every
single session for the last 12 16 weeks
it's ridiculous I think it's gonna be
possessed honestly I'll be surprised if
his opponent as his purple shot as he
has Abby he's a win no doubt about it so
I'm just gonna knock him out he's
training hard for he's mentally ready
for a lot of people doubt his Fitness
but he's got a big tank I know he's
saying knocking out of the first round I
hope he just punishes him for three
rounds and finishes in the third that
big right handle from crashing in and
like I said no matter who you are you'll
feel it when you look in his eyes when
you're in the ring against him he's like
there's [__] fire in there he wants
you so I think that like dog-like
mentality that he's got is going to get
in the wind
six power shoulder seven good
hey that's it stepping nine and that's
it brief
deep breaths
[Music]
[Applause]
third and final round
[Music]
okay ladies and gentlemen
the scorecards are in
and the winner
by majority decision
I trained very hard for this fight as
you can see my body's transformed I was
a different man to the man that Rob
agreed to fight but uh I've always been
underestimated in business everyone
always says I'm a talker and not a doer
I think this proves I ain't a talker I'm
a doer
did it
[Music]